à borodine les stigmates de la guerre
sont visibles l'église du village est
démolie
aujourd'hui quasiment toutes les
habitations porte la trace d'intenses
combats avant la guerre
750 habitants vivaient ici
nicolas est l'un des deux derniers
présents sur place
nous avions deux oies mais c'est sado
les ont tout volé micola marche au
milieu des ruines de sa maison dans son
jardin dévasté les grenades qu'il tient
dans sa main sont celles qu'il a volé
aux forces russes
ils sont venus vivre je leur ai prise
malgré les frappes de ces dernières
semaines il n'a pas voulu fuir après
avoir été pris par les troupes russes le
village est de nouveau aux mains de
l'ukraine mais sa mère nina 92 ans n'ose
plus sortir de son bunker
terroriser et inconsolable
je pleure tous les jours mon fils vazia
est parti il a été tué
le second fils de nina habiter dans une
maison non loin de là elle a été
bombardée par les forces russes à
borodine ou le cimetière n'existe plus
nicolas n'a pas eu d'autre choix kanter
et lui-même son frère
je ne les ai pas enterrer trop
profondément
parce qu'il y aura peut-être une
exhumation peut-être que nous les
enterreront dans un nouveau cimetière
la russie a annoncé mardi des frappes
massives sur tous les fronts en réaction
à la contre-offensive fulgurante des
troubles ukrainienne selon kiev les
bombardements russes ont fait au moins
huit morts et 19 blessés en 24 heures
dans les régions de kharkiv et donetsk